welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss in thor 4 thor love and thunder rap
production with an official first look
from the set which you can almost see
behind chris hemsworth's arms which out
of respect i'm gonna now start referring
to as
love and thunder because you know you
use one arm down under
and the other two never mind but thor
isn't the only damn demigod returning
this week because
the sun's out shining once more on the
guns out of his adopted brother loki
so as we plunge into the sacred timeline
of this loki series i think there is a
way it could set up these two to reunite
once again
as loki promised they would and lucky
for many of you the answers can be found
by staring at this photo longer than is
probably healthy to do so
so thor 4 director and korg actor
taikawatiti shared this image recently
to celebrate love and thunder rapping
production saying quote
this film is the craziest thing i've
ever done and i'm honored to bust my ass
and have a nervous breakdown so you can
all see it in may 2022
craziest thing he's ever done big words
from a guy who played imaginary hitler
now thor's look seems to be inspired by
jack burton and big trouble little china
tight white tank 80s blue jeans it's an
awesome
and crazy film that mixes buddy action
with wild mythological fantasy elements
and taika watissi has cited this movie
as an influence for thor ragnarok and
thor's shirt design
is believed to be a depiction of
yidrasil the world's tree that connects
the nine realms a tree that we saw in
thor the dark world and was likely
destroyed when searcher wiped out asgard
and ragnarok but now the asgardian
refugee settlement of new asgard and
tonsburg norway
seems to have been converted into a
tourist destination with the floating
viking ship equipped with roller coaster
seat harnesses
and a shrine built upon the cliffside
where odin died and hella shattered
mjolnir with that broken uru still
unable to be lifted so they must have
dug out the surrounding terrain
into a mound pedestal for it sam neil is
returning as the asgardian actor who
played odin
alongside luke hemsworth as the thor
actor matt damon as a loki actor
and now melissa mccarthy as the actor
playing hella in the reenactment of
those ragnarok events
and neil said in an interview that he
had no idea what country or planet this
was all set in which makes sense because
they shot this in australia
made it to look like norway in a theme
park stage that once stood on asgard and
perhaps this tank
is merch that thor got from the new
asgard gift shop and something all of us
will be able to buy from spider-man and
captain america sam wilson at the
disneyland avengers campus gift shop
please let's be honest that's what this
is all about now as
korg taika is wearing what might be
another piece of merch a belt buckle
showing the head of a goat or ram
yeah this is likely a nod to the
goat-like beast's teeth bearer and teeth
grinder
who pulled thor's chariot because
stand-ins for them have been spotted on
set
though these also might be just another
ride at the new asgard park like a
kiddie ride that thor is kind of annoyed
at now korg and thor
are standing on the benatar the
asgardian ship as we know the guardians
of the galaxy will be in this movie
and i'm thinking peter quill's celestial
heritage is gonna mark him as a god
alongside thor
that christian bale as gore the
godbutcher has on his kill list
and seeing jack thor on this ship him
full
circle since the last time he stood here
he was messing around with quill
over who was going to be the real
captain of the asgardians of the galaxy
with pillsbury thor boy giving quill a
look like oh
soon i'm gonna get back in shape as the
true man pirate angel who triggered your
manhood
i'm muscular but who are you kidding
quilt you're one sandwich away from fat
yeah right that's true you have put on
weight what but before we continue
thanks to policy genius for sponsoring
this video
if you have anyone relying on your
income you need life insurance it's that
simple
our sponsor policy genius makes it easy
to get life insurance you can save
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
that's money that you can use to do some
fun summer stuff
like take a vacation or build the
world's longest slip and slide but in
all sincerity there are a few things
that reduce stress more than having the
peace of mind that your loved ones will
be taken care of if anything happens to
you you could save 1300
or more per year on life insurance by
using policy genius to compare policies
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place getting started is
super easy first head to
policygenius.com
new rockstars in minutes you can work
out how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price
and when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and scheduling for free the
licensed experts at policy genius work
for you
not for the insurance company so that
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process head to policygenius.com
new rockstars to get started now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice to get it right
under tika's photo luke hemsworth gave
an interesting comment saying it is a
joy to watch two people
expand in so many ways none of those
ways that you both expanded are healthy
but i still laugh and think wow they
really
expanded but then i remember i too
expanded and i'm left feeling
responsible for expansion on all sides
bravo fellas to infinity and beyond just
kidding you look epic so this is why i
think thor's huge arms are both kind of
a
jokey meta aspect of the character but
also something that could be part of the
plot i mean sure hemsworth is always
getting in crazy shape for these movies
and in this case he's hitting the way
it's really hard because he's going to
be playing hulk hogan soon
but the fact that thor so quickly
bounces back into shape
is a reflection of his demi-god status
and i think they may go in the direction
of chris pratt's meta joke and parks and
rec when he lost a ton of weight to
first place star-lord
only thing you did was stop drinking
beer yeah i lost 50 pounds in one month
how much beer were you drinking i know
right
probably too much and that may be the
same explanation the asgardian thor
gives
back to him remember those empty kegs of
asgardian ale and end game that might
have just been a mere month of carb
loading by thor
because really his natural state is
muscular he has super strength what
resistance would he have to be able to
build muscles like that
as i explained in our recent celestial
family tree video which by the way
definitely check that out the earth x
comics tied the asgardians to celestial
origins and it tried to redefine them as
aliens that were manipulated by the
celestials who put them in the third
tier of the celestial mutation cycle
that makes the asgardian's appearance
their powers their identities
all defined by the belief of others so
remember in the first thor movie we saw
odin save the norse people in 965 a.d
from the frost giants and so the very
identities of odin and thor loki hella
frigga heimdall mjolnir everything are
all just
reflections of the mythology of those
who believe in them
kind of like santa so thor's freakishly
expanded
arms as well as jane foster's swole
appearance from the set photos those
aren't just aesthetic superhero movie
prereqs they are
character traits defining their
asgardian status
those guns are what make them a target
for gore
and yeah i do think that applies to loki
too he's a frost giant ward who was
raised and trained with asgardian power
forms of sorcery that we're gonna see
fully expanded in the loki's show
remember the last time we saw loki and
thor together loki told him the sun will
shine on us again
a moment that this loki series is likely
to revisit
in that tva alternate life theater based
on loki's triggered turn away probably
seen the moment of his death and we also
know in the show that loki will say
brother i'm down
you'd better be ready by brother he's
talking to thor
in that moment so yeah here loki appears
to be making good on that promise for
the sun to shine on both of them once
more but
if loki is dead in the primary sacred
mcu timeline where thor 11 thunder
appears to be set and the loki series is
variant
l1130 how will their paths cross exactly
well the answer may have presented
herself under tychus post
jamie alexander the actress who plays
lady sith after being
absent from thor ragnarok sif avoided
hella's massacre of the warriors 3
and is confirmed to return in thor love
and thunder meanwhile rumors suggest
sith may also cameo in loki based on
jaime alexander believed to be in
atlanta while loki was in production
there
lady sith is crucial to loki's
reincarnation as
lady loki in the comics following his
destruction in the ragnarok event
the female form intended to be the
vessel of sif's reincarnated soul
is instead possessed by loki and similar
events
may occur in the loki series which is
confirmed to visit
some alternate timeline in which asgard
still stands
with an alternate throne of asgard that
was not the exact shape as the one that
odin sat on with his two ravens but
rather one that looks like it has a
serpentine design
serpents being beasts associated with
loki and the show appears to revolve
around loki variants including sophia
dimartino
as a lady loki her spirit could end up
in the body of lady sith
as happens in the comics explaining how
a variant loki
and thor end up together and thor love
and thunder with the sun shining on them
once more
confused hey don't worry we're about to
go nuts breaking down loki with same day
after shows and next day easter egg
breakdowns and a full lineup of loki
merch options at new yorkstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel
thank you for watching and uh if you're
gonna say this video was just an excuse
to talk about chris hemsworth's triceps
for eight minutes
you're correct and you're welcome
[Music]
you